[Musik]
die nachrichten des tages heute
samstagabend 19 uhr willkommen guten
abend und schön dass sie wieder mit
dabei sind katja striesow mit allem was
der sport heute ergibt
wir blicken jetzt auf die themen des
heutigen abends
dringender appell an die politik
führende mediziner und wissenschaftler
fordern eine konsequentere pandemie
bekämpfung
ringen um kompromisse die klimakonferenz
in glasgow geht wohl erneut in die
verlängerung und
finaler klick der nationalelf trotz
personal nottwil flick das jahr mit
einem sieg beenden
wie angespannt die korona lage in
einigen bundesländern mittlerweile
wieder ist verdeutlicht die situation in
münchen dort gibt es nur noch 16 freie
intensivbetten ähnlich am limit und
teilweise schlimmer die klinik situation
in thüringen oder sachsen wie die
politik bislang darauf reagiert wird
heute von führenden medizinern und
wissenschaftlern massiv kritisiert und
das sind die aktuellen zahlen das robert
koch institut meldet heute morgen 45.000
81 neuinfektionen und 228 todesfälle
innerhalb von 24 stunden die bundesweite
sieben tage incidents erreicht wieder
einen neuen höchstwert zwei
177,4 und der blick auf die karte zeigt
besonders hoch sind die zahlen im
südosten vier landkreise haben dort eine
inzidenz von über 1.000 einer in sachsen
und drei in bayern aber auch im rest des
landes ist die korona nervosität groß
volker dutschek dazu vier wochen waren
viele schnell test center in berlin
verweist und abgeschlossen seit heute
sind auch hier wieder kostenlose tests
möglich viele die hier anstehen sind
schon geimpft oder genesen und wollen
eine zusätzliche bescheinigung zweig
plus heißt das
ich bin auch für 2g plus weil man
feststellt der doch das 2g vielleicht
allein nicht reicht das auf und zu bei
den test und impfzentren kritisieren 35
führende mediziner und wissenschaftler
in einem öffentlichen aufruf sie
vermissen bei den parteien einen
überzeugenden pandemieplan vorwurf der
expert jeder tag des abwartens kostet
menschenleben und weiter stattdessen
verlagert die politik durch ihr passives
abwarten zunehmend die verantwortung ins
private das heißt in den
ermessensspielraum jedes einzelnen
menschen solch eine haltung ist bei
nationalen gesundheitskrise dieses
ausmaßes nicht angebracht
bund und länder müssen wieder mehr an
einem strang ziehen das fordert auch die
scheidende kanzlerin in ihrem
wöchentlichen podcast als solches
gemeinsames vorgehen brauchen wir jetzt
dringend bei der anwendung des
sogenannten hospitalisierung index dass
es der wert der die zahl der korona
patienten in den krankenhäusern angibt
und uns den ernst der lage zeigt auch
professor clemens lentner von der
münchen klinikum schwabing weiß die zahl
der patienten auf den intensivstationen
wird auch in den nächsten wochen weiter
steigen viele kliniken im süden und
osten deutschlands müssen sich auf
patienten verlegungen vorbereiten wir
haben eben auch schon einzelberichte von
fällen
notfallpatienten können nicht mehr
zwingend wohnortnah versorgt werden zum
teil müssen die längere transportzeiten
mit dem notarzt wagen oder auch mit dem
helikopter in kauf genommen werden neue
sorgenfalten auch bei den gastwirten im
elbe garten in dresden ist andreas
wünsche geschäftsführer wegen der hohen
infektionszahlen sagen viele die bereits
gebuchten advents und weihnachtsfeiern
wieder ab
wir haben ja letztendlich auch mit
weihnachtsmärkten oder auto
veranstaltungen die gleichen probleme es
ist nichts geklärt es ist unklar und das
macht uns schwer zu schaffen solange die
inzidenz weiter steigt gibt es für die
menschen keine planungssicherheit
also die korona krise spitzt sich zu
speziell die lage auf vielen
intensivstationen jetzt geht es um die
richtigen maßnahmen die ampel parteien
wollen die sogenannte epidemische
notlage von nationaler tragweite
auslaufen lassen und das
infektionsschutzgesetz reformieren
starker gegenwind kommt von union und
teilen der grünen fragen wir nach weil
theo koll theo was spielt sich da gerade
im politischen berlin ab also hier wird
hinter den kulissen gerade mächtig
gezählt denn nicht nur die union sondern
auch führende vertreter der grünen wie
der baden-württembergische minister drin
kretschmann waren und fordern dringend
nachbesserungen am gesetzentwurf der
ampel bisher planen die ampel parteien
ja strikte maßnahmen wie beispielsweise
kontakt beschränkungen oder
schulschließungen nicht mehr zuzulassen
und der neue gesetzentwurf verbietet
auch den ländern künftig eigenständiger
maßnahmen nordrhein westfalen
beispielsweise hätte dann beim fall
terry ist keine quarantäne zone um die
betroffenen wohnblocks ziehen dürfen
also da ist erheblicher sprengstoff im
system und was bedeutet das dann jetzt
für die ampel parteien also ich vermute
dass die ampel ihren gesetzentwurf noch
einmal verändern wird verändern muss
angesichts der immer dramatischer
werdenden kroner zahlen sich selbst
sehenden auges der schärfsten
eingriffsmöglichkeiten zu berauben das
macht erkennbar wenig sind die länder
können das gesetz im bundesrat zwar
aufhalten und in den
vermittlungsausschuss geben aber dann
ginge ja noch mehr zeit verloren und das
in einer situation wo eigentlich jeder
tag zählt politisch jedenfalls hat das
ganze das potenzial zur ersten schlappen
neuen koalition zu werden vielen dank
nach berlin theo koll
auch die niederlande kämpfen gegen
steigende infektions und patientenzahlen
dort gilt ab jetzt ein teil lockdown für
mindestens drei wochen jetzt gleich und
dann jeden tag ab 20 uhr müssen
restaurants und bars schließen
veranstaltungen werden eingeschränkt zu
hause dürfen sich die niederländer mit
sieh mal vier weiteren menschen in ihrer
wohnung treffen und sollen möglichst im
home office arbeiten gegen diese
maßnahmen gab es gestern abend heftige
proteste in den haag anne gellinek dazu
es hat schon fast tradition
noch während die regierung gestern abend
die neuen regeln verkündet lassen
ungefähr 200 kritiker der
niederländischen corona politik ihrem
frust raus sie beschießen die polizei
mit feuerwerkskörpern schlagen scheiben
ein die beamten reagieren mit
wasserwerfern fünf demonstranten werden
festgenommen
schon zwei mal in diesem jahr hatte die
niederländische regierung unter mark
rutte alle corona beschränkungen
aufgehoben nun also das erneute
zurückrudern die sieben tage inzidenz in
den niederlanden steigt zu schnell und
liegt mit 534 doppelt so hoch wie in
deutschland
das virus ist allgegenwärtig im ganzen
land in allen lebensbereichen und allen
altersgruppen
erst letzte woche hatten niederländische
krankenhäuser alarm geschlagen die
intensivstationen stehen kurz vor der
überlastung schon müssen andere
operationen verschoben werden in
amsterdams ausgehviertel herrscht am
nachmittag hochbetrieb schnell noch
essen gehen bevor restaurants und
kneipen um 20 uhr schließen müssen die
gastwirte verstehen die welt nicht mehr
das ist skandalös glauben die denn dass
die leute sich um 8 uhr mit den hühnern
schlafen legen die treffen sich privat
und stecken sich dann noch mehr an und
das kontrolliert dann kein mensch bin
nur die traditionelle ankunft des
nikolauses in den niederlanden die hat
die regierung nicht gewagt zu verbieten
es dürfte die letzte massenveranstaltung
für die nächsten wochen gewesen sein
im tarifstreit des öffentlichen dienstes
wollen die gewerkschaften den druck auf
die länder erhöht
verdi kündigte an kommende woche
verstärkt unikliniken und
landeskrankenhäuser zu bestreiten der
verband der universitätskliniken
kritisierte die warnstreiks inmitten der
pandemie scharf die gewerkschaften
fordern für die mehr als eine million
landesbeschäftigten unter anderem fünf
prozent mehr gehalt
in mecklenburg vorpommern ist der weg
für die neue rot rote landesregierung
frei spd und linke haben auf ihren
sonder parteitagen dem koalitionsvertrag
zugestimmt
in der landeshauptstadt schwerin wurde
der vertrag dann am nachmittag gemeinsam
unterzeichnet am montag will sich
ministerpräsident in spe sich im landtag
zur wiederwahl stellen anschließend soll
dann das kabinett ernannt werden
ja es ist das erwartete finale bei der
weltklimakonferenz in glasgow ist eine
gemeinsame abschlusserklärung zwar in
greifbarer nähe aber die im entwurf
enthaltene forderung zum weltweiten
kohleausstieg will nicht jeder stadt
mittragen ursprünglich sollte die
konferenz gestern enden jetzt könnte es
noch eine ziemlich lange nacht werden
über die erklärung und knackpunkte
volker angriff
nehmen sie diesen entwurf an damit wir
den herzen unserer kinder und enkel
hoffnung geben können sie warten auf uns
und sie werden uns nicht vergeben wenn
wir sie heute in stich lassen der
eu-kommissar im heftigen schlagabtausch
indien lehnt den kohleausstieg ab
wie kann man erwarten dass
entwicklungsländer zu sagen sich von der
subventionierung von kohle und fossilen
energie zu verabschieden sie haben
schließlich immer noch mit ihrer
entwicklung und dem kampf gegen die
armut zu tun die entwicklungsländer
haben bereits extreme enttäuschung
darüber geäußert dass das versprechen
das vor sechs jahren in paris von 100
milliarden dollar pro jahr ab 2020
gemacht wurde fakt nicht eingehalten
wird jetzt ende 2021 hätten wir 200
milliarden dollar haben sollen die
strittigsten punkte auf einen blick
klimaschutz finanzierung für
entwicklungsländer globale ausstieg aus
der kohle und internationale
kooperationen zum klimaschutz
kohlendioxid einsparungen sollen dabei
zu einer wertvollen handelsware werden
gewinnbringend verkauft auf sogenannten
kohlenstoff märkten der klimaschutz muss
überall stattfinden die internationalen
kohlenstoff märkte sind dafür ein
wesentliches instrumentarium sie
schaffen anreize für solche projekte in
entwicklungsländern dir ans team gelder
dafür nicht hätten wie zb für dieses
sonnenkraftwerk in chiles atacama wüste
strom liefert es rund um die uhr für
rund
380.000 haushalte
volker angres beobachtet den gipfel in
glasgow volker wie weit ist man von der
gemeinsamen abschlusserklärung jetzt
noch entfernt
also es ist ein spannender nachmittag
die erklärung ist jetzt wieder in
greifbare nähe gerückt das plenum über
die sachfragen ist beendet und alle
mussten drin bleiben und in den nächsten
minuten wird die das plenum wieder
erneut zusammentreten um dann über den
finalen text abzustimmen volker falls
die erklärung spät abends oder nachts
käme wäre sie denn insgesamt ein erfolg
es sieht ganz so aus als wären einige
der strittigen themen abgeräumt worden
wir hatten ja gerade im beitrag das
thema indien mag den kohleausstieg mich
die deutsche delegation hat da
nachverhandelt und hat indien flux
hinter den kulissen mal eben in eine
kooperation mit südafrika eingeholt die
deutschland ohnehin schon hatte
deutschland unterstützt südafrika beim
kohleausstieg indien ist seit heute mit
dabei das könnte die gemüter zu
besänftigen und deutschland hat heute
auch angekündigt zehn milliarden für das
sogenannte santiago netzwerk
bereitzustellen das ist ein netzwerk das
den ärmsten ländern hilft mit den
schäden vom klimawandel umzugehen
stichwort hier ist los und damit so
heißt das hier im verhandlungssaal gang
das sind positive signale und ich glaube
schon dass es heute abend noch zu einem
guten ende kommen vielen dank für dieses
fazit volker andreß es wird also noch
gerungen und gestritten vorüber wo es
hakt und wo man zueinander findet
darüber halten wir sie auf dem laufenden
in unserem klima live blog zu finden auf
zdf heute
die situation an der eu-außengrenze
zwischen polen und boulahrouz auch
us-präsident beiden ist beunruhigt er
habe in der sache auch schon die
regierungen in moskau und minsk
kontaktiert an der grenze zwischen polen
und belarus sitzen derzeit tausende
migranten vor allem aus dem nahen osten
fest bei temperaturen um den
gefrierpunkt sind bisher mindestens neun
menschen gestorben
jetzt nach argentinien wo morgen ein
neues parlament gewählt wird und das
mitten in einer zeit in der die menschen
wegen corona aber auch wegen der lang
anhaltenden wirtschaftskrise ziemlich
stark gebeutelt sind mehr als 40 prozent
der bevölkerung lebt in armut umfragen
sagen eine niederlage für die linke
regierungspartei von alberto fernandez
aus der südamerikanische land steht vor
riesigen herausforderungen wie christoph
röcke rat berichtet auf den ersten blick
sieht es aus wie auf einem normalen
flohmarkt doch die kleidung die estv
sich aussucht bezahlt sie nicht mit geld
denn das ist wegen der inflation immer
weniger wert die währung die hier
gefragt ist sind lebensmittel kleidung
gegen nahrung oder umgekehrt immer mehr
menschen in argentinien sind auf solche
tauschgeschäfte angewiesen ich bin
krankenschwester aber das geld reicht
nicht ich habe drei töchter und ich muss
sie versorgen
die krise argentinien buenos aires
gezeichnet die gassen der innenstadt
sind kaum noch wiederzuerkennen
unzählige restaurants geschäfte und
bürogebäude stehen leer
wir haben ein land mit 52 prozent
inflationsrate im letzten jahr mit 40
prozent der bevölkerung in armut ein
land dessen bruttoinlandsprodukt im
letzten jahr um zehn prozentpunkte
gesunken ist
mit blick auf die bevorstehenden
parlamentswahlen versprechen alle
parteien besserung doch eine schnelle
lösung kann es gar nicht geben vor allem
die korona pandemie wird nach um den
ärmsten zu helfen hatte die regierung
immer mehr geld gedruckt und damit die
inflation noch verstärkt der wert des
peso sinkt die armenviertel wachsen und
den unternehmen die arbeitsplätze
schaffen müssten fehlen die
investitionen
argentinien kommt aus der krise nicht
heraus inzwischen sind millionen
argentinier auf mehrere jobs und täglich
ist improvisieren angewiesen um zu
überleben
in der fußgängerzone spielt ein musiker
alte hits eine traurige endlosschleife
wie die krise des ganzen landes und für
beide gilt wohl sie müssen weitermachen
irgendwie
[Musik]
für uns endet das jahr am 31 12 aber
andere katja sind ein bisschen früher
dran mit dem einläuten das jahresende
zumindest wenn man nationalspieler ist
von deutschland denn morgen abend kann
die deutsche fußball nationalmannschaft
einen haken hinter das länderspiel jahr
2021 machen das letzte länderspiel steht
alle in jerewan gegen armenien und das
team reist positiv gestimmt zur wm
qualifikation
allerdings auch mit einigen
personalsorgen klick muss improvisieren
aufgrund von corona verletzungen und
sperren sind inzwischen zwölf spieler
abgereist auch der einsatz des
angeschlagenen timo keller ist fraglich
für den geschonten manuel neuer wird
marc andré ter stegen spielen und thomas
müller das team als kapitän aufs feld
führen das ziel ist klar wir wollen
gerade weil wir in den letzten spielen
wie ich auch gezeigt haben was für eine
mentalität was für eine qualität auch
die mannschaft hat wollen wir natürlich
schon auf ja drei punkte auch in haben
ihnen den holen wir wollen mit einem
sieg dieses länderspiel jahr 20 21 auch
beenden nach sechs tagen in wolfsburg
sind sie am späten nachmittag abgereist
ziel armenien und drei punkte
in die fußball bundesliga der frauen in
der es heute einen wechsel an der
tabellenspitze gegeben hat der vfl
wolfsburg steht jetzt ganz oben nach dem
1 0 erfolg im spitzenspiel gegen den fc
bayern münchen für den siegtreffer
sorgte in der 69 minute kathrin hendrich
per kopf und damit für den ersten sieg
der wolfsburgerinnen gegen die
münchnerinnen seit mehr als drei jahren
die deutsche eishockey
nationalmannschaft präsentiert sich beim
heimischen deutschland cup in bestform
vorgestern das 4 3 gegen olympiasieger
russland und heute nun ein sicheres 3 zu
0 gegen motiviertes schweizer
nach dem 1 7 gegen die slowakei die
schweiz mit wut im bauch doch die
eidgenossen beißen sich an torhüter das
den strahl miley zähne aus der das 0 0
in die pause retten im zweiten drittel
die deutschen besser im spiel die erste
unterzahl nutzen sie tobias rieder
trifft zum 1 0
kurz vor ende der begegnung fest leo
pföderl apples schuss ins tor ab und in
der schlussminuten tritt patrick hager
ins leere tor zum 3 0 endstand und
morgen geht es dann um den sieg im
finale gegen die slowakei und jetzt noch
zum alpinen weltcup der frauen in lech
zürs in österreich wo lena dörr im
parallel slalom um einen guten siebten
platz eingefahren hat in ihrem letzten
lauf gewann dörr im kampf frau gegen
frau gegen die slowenen rok nick wenn
auch knapp der tagessieg ging
überraschend an die slowenen es locker
morgen dann die männer im livestream 16
uhr auf sportstudio punkt.de dann
herzlichen dank katja die graue
nebelsuppe bekommt morgen einige lücken
dazu erfahren sie gleich mehr im wetter
mit ersten terli
annalena baerbock später interviewgast
im heute-journal bei und mit christian
sievers los geht es gegen 23 uhr 15 das
gesamte heute team bedankt sich fürs
zuschauen wünscht einen schönen
samstagabend tschüss und gerne bis
morgen
[Musik]
schönen guten abend und herzlich
willkommen zum wetter ein ziemlich
trüber tag liegt hinter uns und dazu kam
noch dieses tief von der nordsee zu uns
und bringt brachte etwas regen es wird
allmählich weiter richtung mittelmeer
regen spielt auch in der nacht eine
rolle im süden deutschlands und auch
richtung saarland ansonsten bildet sich
teils dichter nebel zum beispiel die
richtung spree oder mein und auch an der
donau da wird es recht dicht werden ja
und die temperaturen sinken bis auf ein
gerade im osten deutschlands zwei grad
zb an den alpen und 8 grad am
niederrhein oder an der nordsee morgen
dann im tagesverlauf
auflockerungen nach norden hier
norddeutsche tiefebene im westen
deutschlands und auch in den ost
deutschen mittelgebirgen sonnenschein
ganz im süden dicht bewölkt mit regen
teilweise herrscht auch hochnebel und es
ist dann ziemlich dicht der patron
erreichen höchstwerte von 12 grad am
niederrhein und 7 grad zb an den alpen
und die kommenden tage sind erst einmal
noch trocken am montag teilweise
sonnenschein oder auch nebel oder
hochnebel 5 bis 13 grad und den nächsten
regen gibt es erst am mittwoch und damit
einen schönen abend